[Music]
hello hi so you're looking at me from
the
[Music]
street I'm assuming you're not with
anyone never see you with
[Music]
anyone this see moment
daad yeah they died
just before I was
12 I'm trying to write about him at the
moment how's it
going
strangely
hi
hi is this
real does it feel
real our boys back home a son look at
you you were just a boy and now you're
not it was a long time ago yeah I don't
think that
[Music]
matters I've always felt like a stranger
in my own
[Music]
family you always scared of
something always running away do you
[Music]
remember sorry I never came your room
when you were
crying it's funny it doesn't take
much to make you feel the way you felt
back there
[Music]
again you think youd like to be in love
with
him I'd always felt
love this is a new feeling
you you and
me
[Music]
together into the
world